that's a myspace project i started where
I had this idea where anyone could read
a book and write make a song about it
and put it on the net on the mind my
myspace page and I wrote to a bunch of
bands to ask them to do it and so far
and through the process I met some bands
some people that I really love and
gotten involved with some people who
have been really great I'm waiting for
the first song to come in but it was
through that project that I met some of
the people who ended up giving me music
for the website originally when I built
the website i just put you know i put
songs i liked on it I didn't know you
needed permission that's how stupid I am
I like oh yeah Nine Inch Nails rock that
you know put the Dead Kennedys on here
Viva Las Vegas and I was trying to get
the killers because they're from las
vegas for the emitter the musical
website for the project the original
music project and i had some connections
and ended up dealing with their manager
and their lawyer quite a bit who's a
very nice man and you know they're not
going to record a song for some dudes
website it's just not going to happen
but they're they're nice people and I
showed him when I showed him the site
with all you know the nine inch nails
and dead kennedys he's like this is the
best site I've ever seen how did you get
permission to use these songs so then
that forced me to think even harder I
took those songs down because i don't i
don't want to get my butt suit off and i
started contacting some other bands and
some other people i knew some of them
who i knew through me sending out
letters all summer asking hey can you
write a song for me i appeared in The
New York Times Sunday magazine with a
t-shirt for a band called the paybacks
who are a band that I a garage band that
I absolutely love and I struck up a good
unship with their lead singer she gave
me a song she introduced me to their
manager I'm wearing a t-shirt for a band
called the rock and roll soldiers I saw
them at Irving Plaza opened up for four
I don't even know who anymore they were
great and I emailed them back and forth
they gave me a song you know it sounds
like a kind of punky Rolling Stones
thing the guy MC Chris who's a one of
the fathers of nerdcore rap gave me this
crazy star wars song or I asked him for
it I begged him for it and I ended up
with a lot of you know the paybacks
manager gave me you know put me in touch
with all these bands in Detroit who all
gave me butte wonderful wonderful music
Troy Gregory and the stress stepsisters
the octopus freer are all Detroit bands
all unsigned and they're really good
there's all these great music out there
and there's all these tremendously
talented people and we don't know about
any of them no one knew about me you
know because I was all hold up and so I
did them the myspace project is in the
hope that I can keep that if someone
wants to here's a place where they could
post a song that maybe we'll get them a
little attention and it'll be about the
book and I think I did that it's just a
cool art idea to have people make songs
about a book that they read and there's
no money involved I don't want the
rights to a song or anything I just want
something new and fun and so far it's
you know I I really believe that it'll
happen and maybe I'm just stupid and
maybe a year from now there'll be one
song on that site but that'll even
that'll be cool because that's one more
than exists right now
you